Fox News has filed a copyright strike
against us now here's what you need to
understand when someone infringes your
copyright and you file a claim against
them you get two options a takedown or a
strike you can go and say I want this
removed it violates our copyright or you
can say I want them to receive a hard
strike for for stealing my content Fox
gave us a hard strike I believe and
they've also done this to David Pacman a
couple weeks ago two weeks ago now David
PAC
had his video hit by a copyright strike
I believe this is an an egregious abuse
of the system I believe that what we did
was absolutely fair use in any logical
respect and the idea that Fox News
thinks that they should have a monopoly
on a pres on people trying to be the
president more
importantly our factchecking and
commenting on what these individuals are
saying in real time they're arguing no
one should be allowed to do that Fox
News crossed the line